merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur laurent wauquiez monsieur le
président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre je voudrais associer les
nombreux parlementaires élus de la
montagne et notamment la secrétaire
générale de l'anem madame battistel
monsieur le premier ministre la montagne
est inquiète
elle voit s'amonceler les nuages noirs
remise en cause des finances locales
recul de l'aménagement du territoire
avec les ederer grande intercommunalité
où la norme est diluée d'énormes fait
d'ailleurs pour les métropoles urbaines
de plus en plus inadapté à nos vallées à
cela s'ajoutent des problématiques très
quotidienne couverture en téléphonie
mobile internet accès à la santé
inquiétude de l'ensemble du monde
agricole
plus récemment une saison hivernale
marquée par un manque crucial de neige
se fait sentir pour certaines petites
stations
c'est le plafond à noël messieurs
j'espère que vous connaissez
suffisamment la réalité des stations
pour savoir que le chiffre d'affaires
play a chuté de -20% à noël la montagne
vous le savez est une terre de dynamisme
et d'énergie c'est une chance pour la
france mais il faut en prendre soin et
prendre de nouvelles mesures
un acte ii de la loi montagne est
attendue vous avez pris monsieur le
premier ministre je ne doute pas que ça
amène un peu plus de calme dans vos
rangs personnellement à chambéry en
octobre 2000 14 octobre 2014 monsieur le
premier ministre il y à plus d'un an
l'engagement de cette loi montagne nous
avons eu depuis un rapport remarquable
de nos collègues
annie genevard et bernadette laclais à
chamonix en septembre 2015 vous aviez à
nouveau promis
et depuis depuis plus rien pour les
montagnards une parole donnée doit être
une parole tenue
cette loi doit être inscrite avant l'été
s'il vous plaît il y a urgence la
montagne à temps vous pouvez avoir notre
soutien mais il faut maintenant non plus
des paroles mais des résultats et
landry la parole est à madame sylvia
pinel ministre du logement de l'égalité
des territoires et de la ruralité
merci monsieur on retrouve six ont été
évitées monsieur le dégager avec laurent
wauquiez je regrette le ton polémique de
votre question sur un sujet important
concernant l'aménagement des territoires
s'il vous plaît de montagne vous aviez
monsieur le député une autre attitude
le 25 septembre dernier à chamonix quand
vous avez salué la feuille de route
ambitieuse pour ces territoires présenté
par le premier ministre qui justement
veut répondre très concrètement et
efficacement aux préoccupations que vous
avez exprimé que ce soit en termes
d'accès aux services publics de services
de santé mais également de couverture
numérique est d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de ces mesures sont d'ores et
déjà opérationnels
elles ont été portées dans certains
textes par mes collègues par la loi le
numérique par la loi santé d'autres sont
en cours de déploiement et vous le savez
bien puisque le cnm et sa commission
permanente est régulièrement consulté
fait part de ses propositions et je
regrette monsieur le député que lorsque
on vous consulte lorsque vous aurez des
schémas important à élaborer pour
l'aménagement du territoire pour le
développement durable
vous ne répondiez pas aux invitations du
gouvernement pour préparer justement
l'élaboration de ce sera dette qui devra
décliner concrètement un certain nombre
de propositions importantes pour ces
territoires tenant compte de leurs
spécificités parce que c'était bien cela
l'objet du conseil national de la
montagne de permettre un aménagement
durable de ces territoires des mesures
seront prises je pense notamment à la
réhabilitation du son si bouvard pour la
rénovation de l'immobilier de loisirs
mais d'autres sujets que vous savez très
bien monsieur le député donc oui ce
gouvernement est mobilisé pour ces
territoires de montagne comme pour
l'ensemble des territoires de la
république
merci madame la ministre la parole